the higher you get the harder it gets
[Music]
that's life
because this is a war
it's a fight it's a battle
so
how long have you known each other
[Music]
it was like brothers
one day you came back the past came back
too
there may have been a time when Damien
had your back no friends
[Music]
before I got locked up what was the best
cower bro and a fraud
with somebody else live your life
I had to go
I'm just getting started a little bro
I'm coming for it all
it's not gonna stop
and you make
it the one and only Adonis Creed you're
the best pound fighter in the world
three years ago it's been a minute since
you've been out in these streets when I
walked away from boxing I walked away
with some unfinished business
you see that man right there
do you remember him hey hey
no friends in the industry I had to draw
the line between my brothers and my
enemies
let him destroy everything you've found
everything we've built
you out there
you just start fighting